[Música]
para muchos pilotos subir a las alturas
es un sueño finalmente hecho realidad y
el comienzo de una carrera de por vida
pero cuando la pandemia golpeó los
aviones volvieron a tierra y los pilotos
perdieron la esperanza de que algún día
podrían volver a volar muchos están
ahora desempleados y reciben subsidios y
los pilotos en formación que necesitan
1500 horas de vuelo para calificar se
están viendo como sus sueños se
desvanecen hablamos con un copiloto
francés que ahora se ha unido a una
aerolínea de bajo costo en europa del
este ganó 300 euros este mes
llegué a mi límite cuando tuve que
empezar a usar mis ahorros fue entonces
cuando me di cuenta de que tenía que
cambiar a otra cosa porque se te acepto
bueno no tenemos otra opción si los
pilotos no vuelan ya no son empleables
si quieres permanecer en el círculo y
hacer una carrera en el sector aéreo
entonces sólo tienes que armar te de
valor para sobrepasar tiempos como estos
sigue volando sigue ganando experiencia
es la única manera de hacerlo si quieres
quedarte
imposibilitados de volar los pilotos en
formación se arriesgan a perder todo lo
que han puesto en su futura carrera y
las empresas saben muy bien lo
desesperada que es su situación
algunas aerolíneas permiten a los
aprendices volar sus aviones a cambio de
una suma considerable pero los
sindicatos dicen que esta práctica
debería estar prohibida hay ofertas como
estas que le permiten ganar quinientas
horas de vuelo por 39 mil dólares en
adelante estos anuncios siempre han
existido pero ahora son más solicitados
debido a la crisis yo estoy indignado es
abuso es selectivo basado en la riqueza
pero no quiere decir que porque tengas
dinero o sea necesariamente un mejor
piloto quiero que nuestros hijos puedan
convertirse en piloto sin tener que
gastar una fortuna para obtener su
certificado
se espera que el sector de las
aerolíneas tarde al menos tres años en
recuperarse de la crisis de kobe 19
entonces que debería pasar con todos los
pilotos extra en suiza se ha
implementado un plan convertir a los
pilotos en conductores de trenes
nos encontramos con un piloto que vive
en zúrich es uno de los primeros en
realizar el cambio este es el último
avión que vuele es un ave vas a 330
nostálgico un poco sí ahora desempleado
carlos spring lee se prepara para firmar
un contrato con una compañía de trenes
tendrá seis meses de entrenamiento antes
de convertirse en maquinista está en la
nueva compañía mi nueva vida
sí
un cambio radical pero está de vuelta al
ruedo
si el otro lado ya no te quiere entonces
tienes que tragar de tu orgullo y seguir
adelante
verdad aunque contiene fe no otros
compañeros pilotos podrían seguir el
ejemplo consiguiendo la aprobación de
sus sindicatos
el portavoz incluso está alentando al
cambio para ayudar a compensar la falta
de conductores de trenes en suiza pero
se sorprende cuando le decimos que
dudamos que esto funcione en francia
estamos un poco sorprendidos porque
tuvimos algunas reacciones pero no
hablamos con las cadenas de televisión
sobre ello
para nosotros es bastante natural
trabajar así y esperamos que pueda ser
un ejemplo para otras partes de europa
tal vez france a los sindicatos de
pilotos franceses aún tienen que
continuar los salarios en el transporte
ferroviario son después de todo muy
diferentes los conductores suizos ganan
alrededor de ocho mil euros al mes casi
tres veces el salario de un conductor de
tren en francia